comedian M Saturday Night Live alum John
Mulaney is taking a well-deserved break
this August the Emmy award-winning
writer has just finished the first leg
of a nationwide stand-up tour and will
hit the road again
next month all of that follows a
successful run in an unlikely venue the
Broadway stage Jamie whack spoke to John
Mulaney about his multifaceted career
Jamie good morning good morning Dana
that's right while he was on the road we
caught up with John Mulaney at his alma
mater Georgetown University in
Washington
it's a place filled with history
including his own where he made the
comedy connections that helped shape a
stellar career if I'm on the street on
like a Friday at 3:00 p.m. and I see a
group of 8th graders on one side of the
street I will cross to the other side of
the street because 8th graders will make
fun of you but in an accurate way John
mulaney's comedy is cheerfully
self-deprecating they don't even need to
look at you for long they'll just be
like look at how wasted man he got
feminine hips
where do you find yourself pulling
material from now and is it different
than any other time still the same
subject which is me so it's still you
know the Adventures of a sweet idiot I
lived right down there in village C West
those adventures started soon after
Mulaney arrived for college at
Georgetown University where his talents
were noticed by an upperclassman who
would later become a collaborator when
you got onto campus what did you want to
do with your life I wanted to be a
comedian so that worked out now while I
was here I was doing improv comedy in a
improv group called the Georgetown
players improv group the director was a
guy named Nick Kroll he was a senior and
he cast me in the group had I not met
Nick that day and then met Mike
Birbiglia and other incredible comedian
who's helped me out so much it really
would have been a different path so
while I always wanted to be a comedian
there were specific people and moments
here that helped make that happen after
graduation the Chicago born comedian
would spend time in New York crashing
with Kroll and building his onstage
confidence if I had a show scheduled I
always secretly hoped it would be
canceled because I was so nervous and
then there was a turning point where I
started to just enjoy the work of it so
much that I was hoping the show would
not be cancer wasn't long before his
career took off in 2008 you added a
coveted writing job on the Saturday
Weekend Update City correspondent Stefon
where he co-created the eccentric city
reporter Stefon played by Bill Hader do
you have any other recommendations for
folks looking for like a more wholesome
New York experience if you're some dumb
folks looking to just get murdered
and they're just the place for you that
then changed the course of my career
exponentially I was writing comedy to
compare it to writing comedy at Saturday
Night Live it'd be like if you were a
farmer and you're picking up rocks and
then suddenly you're an astronaut on the
moon and you're picking up rocks now
you're still just picking up rocks but
you're on the moon and I would often
look around it's Saturday Night Live and
go I'm on the moon I mean it was just it
was a whole level of rare air that I'd I
can't believe I got to experience we
thrived at SNL as a writer and an
on-screen present I was in love with
Veronica she would babysit us on
Saturday nights and in my head when I
was a little kid I thought that veronica
was like 25 30 years old I was just
talking to my mom the other week I found
out that when I was 10 Veronica was 13
it was his one-hour Comedy Central
special new in town that cemented his
status as a stand-up comic the
performance helped him earn his own TV
show on Fox though the self-titled
Mulaney was cancelled after just 13
episodes
ultimately I think the best thing that
came from it was I was able to say I
thought I wanted that and I don't want
that but it helped me recalibrate what I
wanted to do sometimes big old big old
complicated failures take a while to
unpack the unpacking included hitting
the road starting a tour that became the
basis of a Netflix special fittingly
titled
the comeback kid oh really and I don't
like confrontation because I've never
been in a fight before though maybe you
could tell that from the first moment I
walked out on stage then he reunited
with friend and mentor Nick Kroll to
develop oh hello playing
[Music]
first a sketch on Kohl's Comedy Central
show it then made the unlikely
transition from viral video to Broadway
a wonderful aroma yes well what we do is
it's mayonnaise and tuna fish and we
prepare it and then we put it under the
lights at 5:00 p.m. yeah I think you
were about a week into previews when you
spoke you really weren't sure how it was
gonna be received and now no we weren't
but by the time we got to oh hello we
both entered it thinking this is we
enjoy this so much we want people to
like it but we don't really care that
much what they said if someone who
written a review saying oh hello is
stupid we would have said yeah it is
you're absolutely right that people
liked it was extremely cool
what's next John what do you want to do
after this tour is done I don't make
plans anymore so I'm not living
minute-to-minute a professor here at
Georgetown once said that we were in a
scene study workshop and someone said
well bah bah bah I think my character is
just living day by day and he said well
that's interesting you know Mulaney
lives minute to minute
his current tour will in next year with
three nights at Radio City Music Hall
here in New York where he will be
filming his next one-hour special and a
few missed oh.hello on Broadway it's
available now on Netflix and it's very
funny it's hysterical I watched it the
other night with my son and could not
stop laughing it's wonderful those
characters hit a little too close to
home and I'll come for the tuna fish
sandwich you're welcome Jaime wax thank
you thanks